show you some of these numbers we'll
bring more to you as the day goes on
because we're kind of just loading them
in at the moment and trying to get our
heads random lots of figures today
uh from the government but the one that
we said we were always going to focus on
a lot was this growth so this is gross
domestic product just how fast the
economy is growing national
income and last time around and bear in
mind you know this is before covert
really
really struck so before the lockdown uh
about a year ago
a lot of us thought there was a problem
coming but the economic forecast didn't
seem to buried out this is what the obr
was saying last time
it was going to happen 1.1 growth in
2020. well let's just bring on the
numbers we've had
today to have a look at what's actually
forecast this time around it's
a totally different world we're living
in economically
at the moment 9.9 fall last year that
might get revised but that's kind of
where it is
at the moment and just look at the
difference so you have the economy
starting to bounce back
in the following years and according to
the ob you've got four percent growth
there
uh in the year we're in the moment 2021
a little bit weaker than previously
expected
uh the last time they looked at the
numbers back in november and then you've
got 7.3
in 2022 and their point is that by
midway
through this year here uh 2022 you're
starting to see the economy getting back
to where it was before
the pandemic but here's the thing that i
think a lot of people will be focused on
and perhaps a bit concerned about
is the fact that these bars they are a
little bit taller than the ones that
were
forecast last march but these bars you
know they don't necessarily
speak really strong long-term growth 1.7
1.6 you know not that long ago trend
growth in the uk so the kind of growth
you would expect each year
all else being equal was around two to
two and a half percent so this is weaker
than that
in the long run so people might be
concerned although you're seeing this
the biggest growth that that by my
reckoning by the way is the biggest
growth
of any kind of year since 1941 in terms
of annual
growth rates so a staggering number
there but the real story is you know
what's happening in the future
and what does this mean for the
underlying state of the economy and then
there's also the the
fiscal position so what does this mean
for public finances and it'll be a
similar story you'll see here some
numbers last time around that looked
maybe plausible
uh before coronavirus might have hit so
borrowing the higher these bars are the
more the government is borrowing
uh i should say so borrowing around 55
billion was the expectation last time
let's just look at what happened when
coronavirus struck
it's just extraordinary isn't it so
those are the numbers we've got today
for borrowing in this year that we're in
at the moment coming towards the end of
it 355
billion pounds then 234 so again a lot
higher than last time
and then coming down and down but still
74 billion
in 2025 so you're talking about a higher
level of borrowing than was expected
uh last time around not getting back to
that level
similar thing also for net debt
basically the public finances in a very
very different position to how they were
before this budget we'll bring you more
details as we get them including
as sam was pointing out that kind of
allocation of where the money is being
spent we've got an exciting way
of showing you that on this screen we'll
bring you more of that detail
as the day unfolds